be sure to subscribe to lange focus and
click the notification button hello
everyone welcome to the lange focused
channel and my name is paul today's
topic is the french language or language
lessons as it's called in French French
is a language that really needs no
introduction it's the official language
of France of course but it's an official
language of 29 countries in total that
includes other countries in Europe
namely Belgium Switzerland Luxembourg
and Monaco numerous countries in Africa
Canada where it's spoken mainly in the
province of Quebec the Caribbean South
America and the South Pacific
it's estimated that French is spoken by
between 80 and 110 million native
speakers but that number doesn't give us
a full picture because between 140 and
180 million people speak it as a Second
Language the majority of them in Africa
French is also an important language of
international diplomacy and used to be
the main global lingua franca French is
a member of the gallo-romance branch of
the Romance language family which
descended from vulgar latin just like
all Romance languages did it's also part
of a smaller subset of gallo-romance
called lung the doyen
a dialect continuum in northern France
southern Belgium and the Channel Islands
which includes frosty on the dialect
from which standard French derived and
its closest relatives history in the
second century BCE present-day France
was part of the Gaul region which also
included Belgium Switzerland northern
Italy in parts of Germany and the
Netherlands the Gaul spoke Gaulish which
was not a unified language but rather a
series of Celtic languages and dialects
but very little is known about Gaulish
the Roman Republic conquered Gaul in the
2nd and 1st centuries BCE and in order
to become Roman citizens Gauls were
required to adopt the Roman way of life
including their language Latin being
able to speak Latin became a way to gain
social status economic opportunity and
employment in the civil service over the
next few centuries Gaulish latin
bilingualism became more common and
eventually latin dominated in the
Gaulish languages disappeared the common
people spoke vulgar latin of
ocular form of Latin that differed from
the formal written language and also
differed from place to place throughout
the Roman Empire and I'm feeling deja vu
right now because I think I talked about
this in every video about a Romance
language beginning in the year 375 C II
the Germanic invasions began and
gradually replaced the Western Roman
Empire with Germanic kingdoms the fall
of the empire accelerated the divergence
of vulgar latin into distinct romantic
dialects the dialects of northern Gaul
which would later develop into the lungs
oil changed more than others because of
frequent contact with Germanic languages
like Frankish spoken by the elite the
Frankish elite spoke both Frankish and
romantic and after a while they spoke
mainly romantic dialects but Frankish
left an important footprint on those
dialects French which developed from one
of these romantic dialects got
approximately 550 words from Frankish or
around 13% of the total number of lone
words in French and its phonology was
greatly influenced as well this is a
large part of why French phonology is so
distinct from other Romance languages it
developed from the germanized romantic
speech of the Frankish Eiland but I'm
getting ahead of myself
let me back up for a minute old French
romantic dialects gradually grew into
distinct languages and by the 8th
century the dialects of the northwestern
part of the Frankish Kingdom grew into a
number of dialects that are collectively
referred to as old French which later
began to be called the long the dog as
they developed further there was no
standard form of old French but rather a
dialect continuum one of those dialects
Francia was spoken in a small area
around Paris and it's the old French
variety from which standard French
developed France young is a modern word
at the time the dialect was actually
called France wit that name later
evolved into francais the name of French
today the king in the upper classes
spoke Frankish Latin was the language of
writing and the common people who were
mostly illiterate spoke one of the
various dialects but over the next few
centuries the upper classes began to
speak false young under King Louis the
ninth Francia gained new prestige and
was adopted by the upper classes in
cities around the kingdom
the common people continued to speak
local dialects and Latin continued to
serve as the language of Education the
courts and academia throughout the
Catholic world under King Philip the
fourth French began to be used as the
language of official documents and
government and began to compete with
Latin as a written language middle
French during the middle French period
French changed dramatically particularly
in its phonology but scholars tried to
maintain the language which means that
the written French of today often
reflects the pronunciation of French
before those changes took place old
French had two cases retained from Latin
but those also disappeared in middle
French and this resulted in the word
order of French being more fixed this
was during the Renaissance period when
the cultural dominance of Italy
influenced French 8,000 Italian
vocabulary words entered French 800 of
which are still in use today
in the sixteenth century King Francois
the first signed the ordinance of
vehicle claim which made French the
official language of administration
instead of Latin the Catholic Church
fought hard against this move and didn't
want the Holy Scriptures to be
translated into common languages but
their efforts ultimately failed the
printing press also helped to spread
French because more people could read
and understand it than they could Latin
so publishers printed more books in
French modern French in the 17th century
French took the place of Latin as the
lingua franca of Europe and the Catholic
world this was also the century in which
grammarians sought to standardize proper
French with the publishing of French
grammars and the Academie Francaise was
founded in 1635 with the mission of
promoting proper French and preserving
that form of the language at that time
only a small percentage of the people in
France actually spoke French
most of them spoke other Atlanta Doyle
the other regional varieties of speech
later in 1880 universal education would
be established and French would be made
to the sole language of Education and
the only language permitted to be spoken
at school this measure would push
standard French to be near universally
spoken throughout the country in the
18th century French became the language
of international diplomacy used in
international legal documents and so on
reaching a status similar
to the status of English today French
maintained the status until the time of
the First World War
French may not currently be the most
widely spoken global lingua franca but
it's still an important diplomatic
language it's one of the official
languages of the UN of the European
Union international courts as well as
eight agencies and NGOs why is French
spoken in so many countries around the
world that's because in the 17th century
France began establishing colonies all
over the globe after losing most of
these colonies in wars with other
colonial powers France began a second
colonial empire establishing mainly
colonies in Africa Southeast Asia and
the South Pacific aside from a few
overseas departments and territories of
France these colonies no longer exist
but French is still spoken in many of
those places so what is French like
French naturally shares a lot in common
with other Romance languages and
speakers of Romance languages we'll find
it familiar and comprehensible in many
ways especially in its written form but
its phonology is quite distinct from
other Romance languages and it's
pronunciation is often not intuitive
based on the spelling because its
orthography often reflects pronunciation
from an earlier time pronunciation and
orthography in Old French there were
diff thongs and triphthongs
but these became simple vowels so today
in French there are vowels that look
like diphthongs or trif thongs but
represent simple vowel sounds for
example boo boo Fleur girl you can see
that all of these words contain a single
vowel sound but are spelled like
diphthongs or trif thongs there are also
a number of nasal vowels typically when
an N or an M comes after a vowel it's
not pronounced but the preceding vowel
is nasalized for example fun huh she'll
come here's a phrase with several nasal
vowels boom van blown there are some
exceptions for example when an adjective
or noun takes a feminine ending II
there's Xiang with a nasal vowel but
then there's Shin with an oral vowel and
an end zone
there are also a number of diacritics or
written accents in French four of these
appear on vowels the first is the axial
Teague Xie or acute accent which is used
on the letter e this represents an a
sound for example Luke Fe then there's
the excellent Grove or grave accent with
a and you it's used mainly to
distinguish between otherwise similarly
looking and sounding words for example
ooh
meaning where versus ooh meaning or with
E the grave accent indicates that the
sound is like the en bet as opposed to
an e with an acute accent which sounds
like a then there's the accent Clemmie
this shows that two side-by-side vowel
symbols are pronounced independently for
example currency DOS
meaning coincidence then there's the
circumflex accent which can appear on
any vowel this indicates that the vowel
was historically followed by an S for
example in fact meaning a party just to
illustrate let's look at the Italian
cognate of this word una Festa notice
that there's an S in the Italian word in
an earlier form of French there was an S
after the E and before the T TIGI or
cedilha which indicates that the C
sounds like an S becomes ax please note
that the cedilha is not used when the
consonant comes before an i or an e
because a C in that position is always
pronounced like an S anyway there are
also silent consonants in French
consonants that are written but not
pronounced this includes most consonants
that come at the end of a word for
example shop Pope there there is the
masculine form of an adjective but in
the feminine form of adjectives the
final consonant is pronounced and in
writing and E is placed after it
so there's fair but vest but not all
final consonants are silent certain
consonants are often but not always
pronounced at the end specifically see
our F and L the consonants in the word
careful
for example Aveline avec positive
grammar let's look at word order in very
simple SVO sentences the word order of
French is basically the same as English
for example here's a sentence meaning he
likes movies elem listen word-for-word
'it's he likes the film's so we have
subject verb object but already we see
that something is different from the
English sentence because there's a
definite article in English the definite
article would only be used to refer to
specific films but in French the
definite article is also used for
general statements like this articles in
French are somewhat complex we'll come
back to those a little later the word
order starts to become more different
from English when there are object
pronouns in the sentence so there's the
sentence meaning I see the building
you've read about this month but then
there's jus revoir meaning I see it word
for word it's I it see you see that the
object pronoun comes before the verb not
after it and then there are sentences
with a direct object pronoun and an
indirect object pronoun ballmer done do
locks on this means paul gives me money
paul to me gives some money now let's
change the direct object to a pronoun
Bern we're done this means Paul gives it
to me word-for-word it's Paul to me it
gives and if we make it negative it
becomes even more different from English
Burnham ela dança the nut and pot
constitute the negative it's a word for
word is Paul negative to me yet give not
there are more differences beyond these
but that gives you a bit of an idea for
now basically the word order is more
similar when there are no object
pronouns let's briefly look at a few
other grammatical features of French
gender all nouns have either a masculine
or feminine gender in French the gender
of the noun is also reflected in
articles before the noun and adjectives
that modify it for example the word for
hat shabbu is masculine Lucia Pooh blue
means the blue hat
the definite article and the adjectives
are masculine the word for shirt shoes
is feminine la chemise blue means the
blue shirt the definite article and the
adjectives are feminine articles there
are three types of articles in French
definite indefinite and part
all three types of articles have
masculine feminine and plural forms and
definite and positive articles have
special forms before a vowel
what are positive articles you might ask
well they're indefinite but they refer
to a vague unspecified quantity often
for food or abstract qualities for
example buddha-head you get two meaning
I would like some cake the amount of
cake is vague so we use the partitive
article nouns are almost always preceded
by articles in French unless there's a
different determiner before the noun
such as a possessive pronoun like my or
a demonstrative pronoun like that
negation before we saw the phrase bond
Nomura denpa which is negative with the
negation in two parts na and pop but
it's not always pot that's used no
shammy means never
for example even Ottaviani means he
never works no real means nothing for
example an emotion Jung means she eats
nothing or she doesn't eat anything no
best son means nobody Geneva pet son
means I saw no one or I didn't see
anyone Leah and pest son can also be the
subject of a sentence
their son never knew means nobody came
and Riaan sebasi means nothing happened
verbs the verb system of French is
fairly complex if we include all of the
compound tenses moods and aspects there
are 14 tenses plus the imperative form
let's look at a couple of the basic
tenses in [ __ ] la chemise this means
he's wearing the shirt
Paul is the present tense third-person
masculine singular conjugation but let's
change this to the future tense
he's dr. Holly chemise this means he
will wear the shirt now let's change
this to the imperfect tense imperfect to
mean he was wearing the shirt he's
baaack de la chemise the imperfect shows
that the action was ongoing at a certain
point in the past if you want to express
that the action was completed at a
certain point in the past you can use
the passe compose a passe compose e ela
doc de la chemise that means he wore the
shirt you can see that in the past a
composite there is
auxiliary verb avoir which means to have
and it's followed by the past participle
of the main verb bhakti for some verbs
in the past I compose a particularly
reflexive verbs and those showing
movement a different auxiliary verb is
used at con to be for example elicited
enemies on this means he left the house
you can see that the auxiliary verb is a
form of Ethel rather than evoi
vocabulary as a Romance language most
French vocabulary is of latin origin and
some of the more modern vocabulary or
hybrid words built from both latin and
greek roots english vocabulary has been
greatly influenced by French so English
speakers will likely notice a lot of
French words that look like English ones
the way they're pronounced however is
quite different for example information
samus danger
Don G double dubler licensed resource
and there are a significant number of
false friends between French and English
words that look the same but actually
means something else for example
actually actually more active Elmo
doesn't mean actually it means currently
or right now assist assist e a sea state
means to attend then there's attend act
on a tone doesn't mean to attend it
means to wait there are quite a lot of
false friends like this so you can never
assume that a French word has the same
meaning as a similar-looking English
word now let's look at one final
sentence and see what we find
here's a sentence meaning she went for a
walk to the park yesterday it's a pun
new back yeah word-for-word it's she
herself took for a walk to the park
yesterday L is the third person feminine
singular pronoun next we have the verb
phrase and this year is a reflexive verb
ser' is the third person pronoun used
for reflexive it means herself or
himself next we have the third-person
singular present tense form of Ethel
this is used as the auxiliary verb for
the pass a composite or reflexive verbs
honey is the past participle of the main
verb this is the feminine singular form
which takes an extra e at the end by
itself it's a transitive verb meaning to
take for a walk
but the
plexiform used here means to go for a
walk here we have a preposition meaning
to the two by itself is aa but when used
before the masculine singular definite
article they are replaced by all four
feminine singular it would be a lot and
for plural it would be all back is the
noun meaning park so this whole phrase
means to the park yeah is the adverb
meaning yesterday as you can see French
is a very interesting language for
speakers of English or Romance languages
there are probably many elements of
French that seem familiar but then when
you get into the details of the language
there might be aspects that seem complex
or challenging but French is a highly
rewarding language and by learning
French you will not only be able to
communicate with French speakers but you
will also open the door to a whole new
world of culture literature cinema and
history the question of the day for
native speakers of French in this video
I focused mainly on standard Parisian
French but what regional differences are
you aware of are there any differences
in the French spoken at Belgium
Switzerland Quebec etc and for learners
of French what aspects of French have
you found challenging and how have you
dealt with those challenges leave your
answers in the comments down below be
sure to follow Lange focus on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram and be sure to
subscribe and turn on notifications if
you want to know whenever I publish a
new video and once again thank you to
all of my patreon supporters especially
these people right here on the screen
for their monthly pledges thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]